we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a voicemail
asking a really interesting question
about audio books versus physical books
hey David this is only from Dallas I
love all of your book recommendations
and I've read quite a few of them but
I've never heard your position on
audiobooks uh what do you audiobooks do
you think that it's a cheap way of
reading a book or do you think that it's
useful for people who are often you know
busy with a lot of things going on and
just want to you know hear the book and
audio form okay so here's the deal the
answer to our audio books as good as
physical books you have to first say as
good in what way okay I read fiction at
night before going to bed
the physical process of holding the book
and actually reading it is the point so
in that case my fiction reading at night
before going to bed
an audiobook is not a good substitute if
the idea is to get information from a
non-fiction book then the audio book
while driving in the car or at the gym
or whatever is a better substitute so
you have to ask yourself what is it that
I'm trying to do with the book or with
the information there is one thing about
audio books that's not quite as as
useful I would say which is that the
normal way we read you read a bunch of
lines and then you go back half a line
and then you double check a word that's
a normal process where you might say to
yourself oh no I don't do that I just
read straightforward no I understand we
do it naturally particularly with more
difficult texts you kind of read back
and go up a line or two you can't really
have that same process with the
audiobooks now I get it you can hit back
15 seconds and hear something again but
it is different in the brain so the
studies that have been done are that
audio books are great substitutes for
physical books in many ways but it is
not not the same experience and so the
the answer to the question is it as good
you have to then follow up and say as
good in what particular way we have a
great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the threats and the
suspicious powder sent to Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Brack we are
also going to talk about the FTC getting
involved in making it easier to quit gym
memberships gym memberships and who is
rokana endorsing in the California
Senate race is it Adam Schiff uh is it
um a Barbara Lee
or is it Katie Porter well it is Barbara
Lee we will discuss with you rokana's
endorsement and much more all of it on
the bonus show get access by signing up
at joinpakman.com see you then everybody